okay well firstly the hostages were they  hostages freed in this specific attempt  the breaching of the roof I have to  quickly say that this the fire seems to  be burning pretty heavily now  very very thick dark smoke coming out of  it out of the roof of the building  the were were hostages released in that  or were they part of a release of people  who have been inside the shopping center  for the last two days certainly there is  a sense here that that is much more  likely and less boohoo reportedly been  killed had hostages with them again it  is impossible to know that we've been up  fearing from the authorities here that  hostages have been released but they  seem to be using that hostage for anyone  who is caught inside the shopping centre  when this began at lunchtime on Saturday  we know there's been a small drip of  people coming out over the last day or  so